I recently saw a top 10 sci-fi women
list and it was just crap I mean I had
the chick from Hunger Games in it
I don't get it
so I thought I'd do my own welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and move your
Channel
let's get straight into this
Michelle Nichols Lieutenant Uhura Star
Trek the Original Series and then the
following movies
Not only was this woman Kick-Ass in
actual the series you know she was
actually in a prominent role which was
really the first time for a major
Network television show particularly at
that time period She was brave enough to
do the storylines like the Kirk kiss and
she was a phenomenally talented actress
singer performer
the character though it wasn't just that
she was a talented and capable officer
she actually stepped up and did the job
a few times now even though uhura's
character in Star Trek was still a
little bit in the background
in the newer series she stepped up in
the JJ Abrams movies she was a far more
formidable character
but the Nichelle Nichols it's because of
the time
it's because of how Brave she was to
even take on the role and then actually
fight for the role that really really
impressed me and obviously Michelle
Nichols passing recently is another
reason why I wanted to add it to the
list
the one story though about Michelle
Nichols that I love the most
is that after the end of the first
season she was generally considering
leaving Star Trek she really wanted to
get into Broadway and she genuinely
thought her character was kind of being
pushed a little bit more into the
background anyway
but then she saw Martin Luther King at a
party it turned out that Dr King was a
Trekkie when Michelle Nichols told him
that she was thinking about leaving he
not only said that she shouldn't leave
he told her that he couldn't
he told the Uhuru was a role model for
an entire generation of young black
women and that it was her duty to
continue playing the role so of course
how do you argue with Martin Luther King
she didn't
and we got one of the finest female
characters in all of sci-fi
number four I went with a Star Wars
character and it's not the one you think
because yes I could have gone the easy
route Princess Leia Carrie Fisher that
is the route that they went on this list
that I watched that I really didn't like
I went a slightly different way Rogue
one is one of the most interesting Star
Wars movies made Under the Disney era
you could actually argue it's the only
interesting Star Wars movie made in the
Disney era but I'm not gonna open that
can of worms I just thought this was
such a clever movie maybe a bit long it
could have been edited a little bit more
to make it a little punchier but it was
just such a clever film it was so clever
how it ran into the New Hope movie they
got the style right I thought the end
scene with Darth Vader was just
but another reason why I love the movie
was Jin erso her character was
formidable now none of the women on my
list are characters with superpowers or
special abilities or anything like that
they're all characters that just
throw themselves 100
into fighting against a problem
none more so than erso now her parents
were killed by the Empire her
motivations were not complicated they
were pretty simple Revenge
but she was willing to do anything it
took including sacrificing herself to
get what she wanted to hurt the empire
now she was phenomenally good in this
movie her character was well-rounded she
had she was played by an amazing actress
and I just loved everything about this
entire film I love that it spun off into
the series that we got to see and or
it's a shame we're not going to see urso
in that
unless they change Canon this is Disney
so they might I have no leaned back into
this list that I saw and go into two
characters that really deserved to be in
any list again of male or female great
sci-fi characters
first of all I've gone with Ellen Ripley
now Sigourney Weaver's character in this
was really one of the first times I ever
really remember seeing a sort of
Hardcore action female character she
could do anything the men could do and a
lot of the time do it much much better
she was intelligent she was a bit feisty
and she was determined when she came up
against an enemy she stood up she fought
back not just with her Brawn but with
her intelligence Sigourney Weaver who is
a formidable lady herself played this
character perfectly in alien and then
more so in Aliens we got to really see
what Ripley was all about and even the
Space Marines stopped and took notice
she was formidable she was one of the
first female characters to not just run
around screaming and I just loved that
that it didn't matter that she was a
female character
she was just a powerful one Sarah Connor
is obviously going to be in at number
two mainly because of Terminator 2 but
also because of The Following TV series
that got so cruelly cut short
the whole sort of idea of Terminator 2
is that it was supposed to be completely
different to the Terminator movie and
lots and lots of ways and none more so
than Sarah Connor's character it really
epitomized the change that she went from
that doe-eyed big hair 80s sort of
traditional really sort of female
character in a way
to an action hero now in the first
Terminator movie we did get to see Sarah
Connor's character develop to the point
actually that the Sarah economy then got
to see in Terminator 2 completely made
sense it was 100 logical that she would
go that way and that she would go a bit
crazy in the process
in the TV series we got to see that
developed even further and I was gutted
when that got canceled because even the
guy from 90210 that was in it was pretty
good Sarah Connor was all about
protecting John at any cost
whatever happened to her didn't matter
as long as John survived I cannot do
anything but respect a character and any
person I ever meet in real life that has
that kind of attitude and that kind of
Drive I find it incredibly impressive
and Incredibly inspiring because that is
the one thing about all of the women on
this list they are inspirational even
though at times they lean into some of
the female stereotypes and then go
beyond them
all of these characters were written as
just brilliant characters
it didn't matter that they were female
but who is top of my list who is my
favorite female character in all of
sci-fi the one that I think kicked ass
best
of course it's Samantha Carter I mean
hello you can get this t-shirt on
silvestrek.com by the way
she was phenomenal how many characters
in any of sci-fi do you know blew up a
star there's not many I love this
character mainly because she came in
very early on and stamped her Authority
that by calling Assam O'Neill thought it
was going to be a guy
she stamped on him immediately when he
made any suggestions such thought I'm an
Air Force officer just like you are
colonel and just because my reproductive
organs are on the inside instead of the
outside
doesn't mean I can't handle whatever you
can handle I'm actually he wasn't being
sexy at that time he just doesn't like
scientists and now early on in sg1 there
were a couple of episodes like
emancipation that did make the point
that Samantha Carter was a woman but
that she was still a very capable
officer what the colonel is saying is
have you ever pulled out of a simulated
bombing run in an F-16 at eight plus G's
yes
well it's way worse than that the gender
agenda
was kind of evident in a couple of those
episodes but they moved on from it
quickly Samantha Carter just became a
pivotal member of sg1 it didn't matter
that she was a woman she was just as
good a shot as anybody else on the team
she was just as good a warrior as anyone
on the team and she was a damn State
smarter than anybody on the team
but honestly she had her flaws she had
her weaknesses that her job was the most
important thing in her life and that
really didn't leave time for an
emotional love life however much she
wanted one Sheen loved O'Neill but that
was forbidden fruit
she had emotion at times but she was
also willing to do what needed to be
done
Samantha Carter is not just one of the
greatest female characters in all of
sci-fi she's one of the greatest
characters Full Stop in all of sci-fi
but guys get to the concert tell me what
you think about my list of my favorite
top five female Kick-Ass characters in
all of sci-fi I'd love to know what your
list would be where am I right where am
I wrong get into the comments and tell
me if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe and don't forget to hit
that Bell notification so you never miss
any of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos do Premiere
first and for a small contribution each
month you get to see them without the
adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
I've just been editing this video and
I've just realized I've made a horrible
error
Zoe Washburn needs to be on this list
Xing was an incredibly powerful woman
and one that I would not want to meet
down a dark alley
she was more terrifying even than Jane
on the series of firefly I think Jane
was actually scared of her
I know wash was
so yeah I'm gonna drop the chick from
Star Wars even though she was brilliant
and deserves to be on the list I'm gonna
drop the chick from Star Wars and I'm
gonna throw Zoe Washburn from Firefly in
at number four
don't I've made I've done it
oh